[Music]
it's something that you feel a
connection with people automatically i
don't think there's a better feeling you
can kind of move the night with the
music and the energy of the people can
also move me
it just really feels fulfilling
[Music]
hi i'm angel i'm dren
we're twin djs and producers
what makes a good dj is being observant
if i play one track and i'm just like
everybody really responded to that it's
knowing in your head in a split second
i've got 10 other checks it sounds just
like that
we do switch off usually every 30
minutes
she can kind of like move off of what i
did
when we're not playing we're watching
the audience she'll be playing and i'll
come over and listen up and like play
that next i know when my twin has it
we'll be okay
we've been the grew up in the bronx new
york and it's a really jamaican area a
lot of reggae playing out in the streets
all the time
in fifth grade we entered this program
that helps inner-city
youth that are generally underprivileged
we got very lucky but some kids don't
get as lucky we got through middle
school and high school and we got into
dartmouth and we both decided to go
there
so when we graduated we came back to the
city
i was playing with equipment on and off
i went home one day and i told her like
this is what we have to do
after you graduate from college nobody's
thinking you'll then go on to become a
dj
it was one of those moments where you
had to be resolute in what you were
doing
there's no kick yet
[Music]
and then the base heads i kind of like
it
i think dji is definitely a
predominantly male industry
we've heard some negativity from
not even other djs but people and
audiences and i think it's been
surprising just because it doesn't feel
like djing should be a gendered thing i
take a burden upon myself to perform
better because
we are women we do get a lot of good
feedback from girls and women who want
to learn a deal who want to learn how to
dj
if someone told me that i would end up
being a professional dj with angel i
would not have believed it
when you follow what you like and you
follow your dreams it can take you
anywhere
[Music]
you